welcome to the final top five of 2016
I'm Walter benezia and here we count
down the best and worst performances of
our most beloved actors most great
actors have at least a few bad
performances needless to say I did find
a few for mr. Harrison Ford this top
five is the result of a Twitter poll I
put up asking who should be the last
actor covered on top five in 2016 more
polls will be going up on there soon so
if you want your voice heard on who or
what I will cover next make sure you
follow me on Twitter at awesome
underscore Walter Ford has been on the
scene for over 40 years while he is one
of the biggest actors of our time he has
had a few missteps here in there even
Indiana Jones can fall into a trap once
in a while quite literally in this case
but as we've seen in his older years
Harrison can still be as charismatic as
ever when he wants to be emphasis on
when he wants to be today we take a look
at the roles that just didn't quite land
for him these are the top five worst
performances of Harrison Ford number
five
Bob falfa in American Graffiti wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
now hold on a second before you start
typing up your angry comments let me
explain something I really really like
American Graffiti
it's a classic that I think most
everyone should see if for nothing else
to see a pre Star Wars George Lucas
direct a good movie I have no real
issues with the movie whatsoever I am
just focusing on Harrison's performance
here okay release the hey let the heat
flow through you
American Graffiti follows four teenage
friends on their last summer night
before leaving for college it's the
early 60s and in this love letter to
that error we hear some classic music to
go along with the drama and fun of a
rowdy unpredictable light for the youth
of Modesto California I know I'm in the
minority in this one and I accept that
I just think Harrison is pretty bad in
this movie
[Music]
what do you say his delivery is terrible
and no it's not the writing every other
actor in this film can for the most part
make this cheesy dated dialog work and
it fits in with the tone of the movie
just fine it's not the writing it's the
bad delivery you will see a stranger
across a crowded in care or is just
trying too hard or both but this pre han
solo performance just comes off awkward
and not intentionally awkward just
awkward you're supposed to be fasting in
the ballet ma'am but it can't be your
car it would be your father's car he's
not in the movie for that long so it's
not even close to his worst performance
but it does fit in for me at a distant
number-5 further down the rabbit hole we
go number four
Quinn Harris in six days seven nights
this movie is terrible
although Harrison doesn't seem bored
like he sometimes does maybe he was just
happy to be on vacation a career-driven
woman named Robin travels to the South
Pacific with her boyfriend Frank for a
much-needed getaway
however when she's forced to tend to
business on her time off she needs a
pilot and that Mead is filled by a man
named Quinn on their way to Tahiti a
storm interrupts the plane ride and
forces Quinn to land on an uninhabited
island with no apparent way off the pair
bicker while trying to come up with a
way to get noticed for a rescue this
movie was directed by Ivan Reitman and
starred an Hache who was pretty
insufferable here and seemed to drag
four down with her what the hell did you
do what day you you waking hurt only God
named Claire there tuna goddamn palm
tree I shot the goddamn tree have yet
enrolled into me I was trying to signal
the goddamn plane Ford plays sort of an
eccentric pilot who's a pretty laid-back
guy almost too laid-back sometimes 50/50
I still look good I still am good just
about every actor in this movie is awful
David Schwimmer may actually be the
worst but Ford isn't immune to this bad
script either you talk too much
you're opinionated you're stubborn
sarcastic and stuck up your ass is too
narrow and your hips are too small at
least he has a pulse here for the most
part it's not so bad that it's worth
watching it's more forgettable but this
was pretty lame Danny Trejo was in it
for a bit though what's on Matt nuit
us let's get off this godforsaken Island
and count down our top three number
three
captain second-ranked Alexei Vostok off
in k-19 the Widowmaker you know what
would be great if Indiana Jones play the
boring Soviet submarine captain said no
one ever
based on true events and at the height
of the Cold War Soviet Russia tasks
Alexei Volkov with captaining the
nuclear missile holding submarine k-19
the bad luck that the sub holds gets
worse under foster crops command as a
nuclear core meltdown begins on board
the damage that a core meltdown would do
surpasses the destruction of the ship
and crew and may possibly cause a
full-on war between the US and USSR the
ship's crew already doesn't like their
new captain and in the middle of a
critical hour they must choose to trust
him or not I don't mean to keep harping
on accents in these worst videos but
this one is unavoidable
Ford's Russian accent is lazier than his
acting in this movie he's dead
stay with the buddy till the ambulance
comes the rest of you back to work it
comes and goes without much thought I
could look past it if it seemed like
Ford gave a damn about being in this
movie it's a great example of a grumpy
older Ford performance continued the
dive to 300 meters 300 meters is close
to crush depth I know kathryn bigelow
directed this claustrophobic undersea
tale and while depressing it's actually
not too bad it can be pretty dull
especially when Ford's on screen but
it's okay I guess the score is pretty
good and Liam Neeson actually turns in a
decent performance even if his own
conflicting accent is prominent
throughout needlessly endangered us both
and it's cruel 200 million Soviet
citizens are depending on us on us cut
the Vostok off to save them from nuclear
attack you risk them as well I took this
boat and these men to the edge because
we need to know where it is by the way
is it weird that every time you hear the
Soviet national anthem I instantly think
of Ivan Drago and rocky 4 also Hans from
the muddy ducks is in this so that's
cool bottom line I doubt there's a
single person on this planet that wanted
to see Harrison Ford in a role like this
including Harrison Ford number 2
Detective Sergeant Joe Gavilan in
Hollywood homicide uh this was a movie
in a loose sense in this action buddy
cop comedy veteran detective Joe Gavilan
has a second job as a real estate broker
while his partner young hotshot Casey
Calvin is pursuing acting on the side
together they're an unlikely team who
solved mysteries and chase bad guys I
guess honestly I couldn't tell what they
were doing with this plot it really made
no sense yeah Hollywood homicide is
awful apparently Ford & Hartnett really
didn't like each other on set and I'd
say you can see it a little bit in the
film fuck you very much Ford looks
pretty bored again but that's mixed in
with the film's obnoxious tone and
blatant intention to annoy you since
being recorded this will reflect very
badly on you it
allegations are co-mingle funds there
are a few WTF moments thrown in there
too
[Music]
no funny amusing what emotion am I
supposed to feel after seeing that why
do you want to do something stupid like
acting Ford steals a little girl's bike
- yeah you showed her it's really
difficult for me to describe this movie
it's seriously hard to follow and Ford's
bizarre performance just makes it worse
and the number one worst Harrison Ford
performance is Jack Stanfield in
firewall Jack Stanfield works at a bank
as a chief of security when a group of
hoodlums attack him and his family then
hold them hostage it's up to Jack to get
them what they want money from his bank
while trying to find a way to save his
family and expose the team of thieves
I'll mention this off the bat towards
the end of the film it starts to pick up
a little bit and becomes easier to watch
there's a fight scene between Paul
Bettany and Harrison Ford that's
actually pretty good and well
choreographed now everything else pretty
much sucks his family is being held
hostage and this is his initial reaction
Jesus at the beginning of the film I'm
not even sure if Ford was conscious
merger goes through me get some budget
will go and replace the whole thing
at least Jamie Lannister is here to give
us sick burn to Ford's daughter why do
you hate us so much I don't hate you sir
just don't care about you most of the
film is as dull as Fords performance we
have a few riveting scenes surrounding
the family dog though are you doing
let's find my dog got a lot of fond
memories of that dog he was really bad
in this one the good news is I think
he's chosen better roles recently and
looks invested in most of those films
he's had a legendary career and I think
he still has a few great performances
left up his sleeve pack up your shit and
get out of here
no I want to hear what you guys think
what is your least favorite Harrison
Ford performance and/or movie leave a
comment and let me know if you haven't
already make sure you go back and check
out my top 5 best Harrison Ford
performances and make sure you check out
awesome comics from yesterday a
Christmas Carol + Zack Snyder equals a
Christmas Snyder II and it's cool well
there you have it the last top 5 of 2016
thank you for watching up to this point
we're going to be taking the next week
off but I will be back the following
week with something a little bit
different we're gonna be changing up top
5 going into the new year and for the
first four episodes in 2017 we're going
to be doing something a little bit
different a little fun and I think you
guys are really going to like it
we'll be going back to the actors and
actresses probably in February so thank
you for watching up to this point and
look forward to us coming back because
it's going to be a lot of fun follow me
on twitter at awesome underscore walter
to take part in more polls about what i
may cover in the future have a happy new
year and I'll see you in 2017
[Music]
[Applause]
you